Daniel, thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me.
It's so good to have you.
Where are you calling from right now?
Tel Aviv.
Tel Aviv. And how is everything
with the quarantine and with covid-19?
It's seems reasonable now actually.
We're starting to see the end.
And people and more going outside.
And yeah, I'm pretty optimistic around that.
At the moment.
Fantastic. You know, this interview
is going to be published in a few weeks.
So, I'm always curious to see
how the state of during the interview time
and then, what actually happens
once its published.
So, let's hope that everything
is open by then.
And everything's wonderful.
Daniel, you're working on the one of the
coolest companies that I know.
And that's because I'm a fitness and health
sort of fanatic myself.
I used to be so passionate about
what I put in my body.
And how I treat myself.
And now with the quarantine,
I've been indulging in a little bit
more pizza than I should.
All of us. All of us.
Daniel, you know, before we get into Lumen,
give me a brief roundup on everything
done up to now.
Because you're a seasoned entrepreneur.
You've had a lot of experience
before coming to Lumen.
And then let's dive in to this
incredible device that you've created.
Okay. Okay, so I'll try to be brief.
So, I've been entrepreneur for the
past 16 years.
So, Lumen is my third company.
But talking about founder, it's the second.
But kind of my professional life
this is almost all I did.
Before that, as kid in the boy scouts
love people interaction and so forth.
And then the navy. As a navy officer.
Wow.
So that's I think kind of gave me
a certain skill sets to
that I work pretty well with people.
Yeah.
But nothing professional really
to dive into.
And I think I became a good learner.
Around those period of time.
So, that's it.
So, my journey began very naively.
In 2005, I sits next to
at the first day of school in university,
in IDC in Herzliya.
I sit next to my founder today
and partner for a lot of time.
We sat next to each other.
His name is Dror.
And very naively we started talking
about doing something on the internet.
And we build something.
We build a product.
We found our missing link,
the technical guy who was
was our CTO in all companies,
and stills is. Avi.
And we build kind of a search engine.
A very visual one.
That helps people kind of browse through
the top websites in every category.
That was the first initiative.
We've made every mistake possible
in a book.
We build a product. Never launched it
for two and a half years.
We was tweaking it and improving it.
No one ever experienced that.
And then we launched it to
TechCruch shipT.
And at the time we launched it,
we decided that no one
will actually use that engine.
So, there's better one out there
And we killed it.
And immediately got start pitching
something else basically.
The second day of the conference,
we started pitching something
completely different.
And that thing was a tool for website
and publishers to integrate apps
into services into their platforms.
And that was our second company basically.
That was Wibiya.
And Wibiya was kind of fairytale story.
Two and a half years.
Raised about $2.5 million.
Then actually sold it to another company.
Another Israeli company called Conduit.
And stayed there for two and a half years.
And then, the three of us left and
started basically three months later,
started working on Lumen.
So, Daniel you actually went
with your two co-founders throughout this
whole entrepreneurial journey for 15 years.
Which is also is not that common.
So, I actually saw that from
The Top Reasons Why Companies Fail,
one of the top reasons is that
Founders have a dispute at some point.
and they part ways.
But you haven’t experience here.
Do you think that you sort of, the time
that you were all in the army
not necessarily together but you all went
through this camaraderie experience,
and you learn what it takes
to work with people even if
you don’t necessarily see
I try and everything?
I'm not sure it's the army.
I think it's the type of person
that you worked with.
And not necessarily the army.
Yes, the army maybe gives you some
skills around that.
But you can take it from a lot of places.
And it's mainly the people you choose
to work. And to be honest it's also,
it's a process. Right?
Oh yeah.
All of a sudden, a lot of ego on the table
when we've starting working together
and everything was much much harder.
And yes, we're fortunate to continue together.
But for Lumen, what we did
was even more, was more dangerous.
That's basically, Lumen was incubated
in my house.
So my spouse Michal,
and her twin sister Merav.
They basically they're babies.
So, they are the science nutrition.
the physiology.
Everything smart behind what we do.
I fell in love with the concept.
The concept of measuring and understanding
something that really happens in my body
that potentially will have an impact on
on the way I train.
On the food I eat.
And on my health in the future.
And I was fascinated by that.
And fortunately, I have a very good teacher.
Every evening on the couch,
explaining to me the science
of how physiology works and everything.
And somehow, I don’t know how I got
my co-founders Dror and Avi to join me
into this journey.
I know how I told them a very big lie.
In the sense I told them,
"Listen, it's going to be a breeze.
It's hardware. But we get the sensors.
We get design. We do a kick starter.
After a year, we have a product out there.
That was 2014.
And it only took a six years
to get the product out eventually.
But we did.
I love it. I love that story.
So, where is Lumen right now?
So, May 2020, what's happening with Lumen?
Lumen started in 2014.
But actually in a way,
Lumen is really starting now.
We launched a product to our backers.
Who backed us on Indiegogo.
10,000 of them.
In 2018. Yeah, 10,000 of them.
And kind of middle of 2018.
It took us a lot of time
but we delivered the product in January.
Most of the products brought to customer
in January and now we're actually
feeding from their feedback.
And continuously improving the product.
And very soon, in about two weeks’ time,
We're going to publicly launched
what we're doing after we get some feedback.
And we got more inventory to sell.
So yeah.
Lumen is still middle of the journey.
but for people of outside of the company,
in a way, it's just a start. Just the beginning.
Oh, I'm sure.
So, first of all Indiegogo.
I don't get to meet many people
that have launched such
successful campaigns on Indiegogo.
I mean, 10,000 units sold.
That's a lot of confidence.
And a product that hasn’t been launched yet.
What was that experience like?
Going on crowdfunding and trying
to get the public to really buy
into this idea of this hardware
that's gonna help you gain control
over what you put into your body.
Yeah. It was fascinating because,
you know we’ve been pitching this concept
and we're actually been testing it
with prototypes since 2017.
But still, for someone to take money
out of the pocket and pay for something,
for a device and really engage with it
that was, you really need to understand
how you're going to sell this.
And why would people buy it?
And we really didn’t want this
to be a concept of this is a cool gadget
that you just buy or another gadget.
We wanted this to be tied into something
people care about.
And nutrition is something people are
deeply passionate about.
There is a community of people who are
obsessed about it for different reasons.
Working out. Losing weight.
And so we took a shot at this.
Basically not positioning this as a device
that can do thousands of things.
But actually more capturing and showing you,
If Lumen is in your hands,
how can you use it?
What's the value for you?
And I think, as opposed to many other campaigns
that are basically showcasing technology,
we were a lot more focus on the experience.
And we kind of knew that
the experience we were offering
is something that people will actually
be using and succeeding with.
So, that's I think the theme to that is
pre-solid start to work on a campaign with.
To be honest, I didn’t do a lot in the campaign
It's also finding the people who are
talented around that.
And my partner Dror has led this concept
almost completely alone
with a very selected few.
And he did the phenomenal job.
Definitely. Definitely.
So, give in a few sentences,
what am I experiencing when I hold
Lumen in my hands and trust me
I'm gonna be holding Lumen in my hands
sooner or later.
Okay. So, yes.
This is Lumen basically.
It's a very small device
that you can carry with you.
or just put in your stand.
And you breath to this in the morning.
It's not a normal breath.
You inhale air through it.
And everything is guided through enough.
You hold the air in your lungs
for ten seconds and you exhale.
And what Lumen does is basically
sampling the CO2 content of your breath.
And through that, it basically reflects to you.
Whether you're currently using fats
or carbs for fuel in real time.
And it changes. Right.
Our body can use fats and carbs.
And those are two different fuels
for probably different goals in a sense.
But, what you want to be doing
if you're waking up in the morning
on s fasted state, you want your body
to be using fats.
Because night time is the time for the
body to transition to fat burn in a sense.
So that's a first moment in the day
that you can get a sense of
control freely what's happening.
What happened yesterday?
Have you been eating too much?
You ate too late.
You drink alcohol in the evening.
Stress. Sleep deprivation.
All of those are preventing you basically
from getting into fat burn in the morning.
But then, what do you do with this information?
So, let's say I get this information.
Okay. Yeah, fine. So, I'm burning carbs.
I'm not burning fat. What do I do now?
So, what Lumen provides you with is
a kind of actionable insight
on what you should be doing.
So you get a nutrition plan for today,
what you should be eating.
You should follow that.
It's insightful around workouts.
It's insightful around how much carbs,
proteins, and fats you should have.
And it actually, gradually becomes
more and more actionable
the way we design the product.
And once you followed that,
you measure again the next morning.
And you start seeing the change.
So, it will piss you in a way.
There is a learning experience
in that journey of self-exploration.
And it teaches you what works for you.
Which not necessarily will be the thing
that will work for someone else.
So, and how quickly will I see this change?
And how quickly will I see the progress
that I'm making towards my,
let's say my goals to burn more fats.
So, how quickly will I notice this change?
It really depends on you.
In a sense people who are insulin resistance,
or having sort of resistance,
who are pre-diabetic will probably
take a little bit longer to see the impact.
But generally, healthy people
it's a matter of days.
Of following a nutrition plan and seeing that
And it's an interesting feedback
because you can measure that very easily.
Okay. One night of playing poker,
eating pizza with friends.
You wake up on a carb burn very easily.
Which is okay, right?
It's a start of life.
But you wanna have the tool
that kind of guide you. Or the compass
that gives you direction when you're good.
When the things you did are impactful.
Or when it's not.
And you can get back on track with it.
Definitely. So, two questions here.
Because changing human behavior,
and changing consumer behavior
is difficult. It's almost impossible.
I have the pleasure of working with
Dan Ariely at Irrational Labs
a few years ago, and our research
and our work was centered around,
How can we think of consumer behavior
on technological products and guide for
different behaviors based on
what we're doing?
And part of Dan's premise is that
you know, we are irrational beings.
It's very hard for us to change our behavior.
But it's much easier for us to
change our environment which will
force us to change out behavior.
So how do you perceive users
adhering to this nutrition plan
and changing their behavior's the result of
seeing these results on an app?
Is that something that you really think
is gonna happen?
Or have you been seeing that it's happening?
We're already seeing it's happening.
But it's a process of designing.
So the device is really only the first phase.
Right?
The experience that the users go through,
in terms of insight,
and what should he do about it
as you said rightfully,
it's happening in the app, right?
That journey is really happening through
content in the app.
Sure.
I can give you an example exactly pointing
to the point that you're raising.
When we launched this,
or gave it to beta users of early batches,
we told them, "You can measure in the morning."
And before lunch. And after lunch.
Before workout. After workout."
We gave them tons of opportunities
to measure and understand stuff.
And it was a bit overwhelming to them.
And then what we did is,
What is the ritual?
The one ritual that we need to nurture
that will become maybe the default.
Basically, we have a potential to capture
a moment of the users’ day.
When is that going to be?
And how much value we can
focus on that moment?
And that moment is morning time.
We find that morning time at fasting,
there is something, there is a,
it's a mindful moment that you can take
for yourself and people can get used to it.
Basically, like brushing their teeth, right?
Behavioral change is hard but people are
relatively okay with brushing their teeth.
I hope.
And so, I think wellness rituals,
have a potential to make an impact
and to become habit
if there is a feedback loop, right?
It's easier to some extent
if you can measure something
that gives you a reflection of
what's happening and where you're heading.
Totally. And I think that goes back
to a lot of research by [--]
and have information.
And atomic habits that I've read recently.
But how do you do these incremental steps.
And one of the most important part
of habit formation really is this idea
that you have this quick feedback loop.
And you can see this very incremental
small progress every day.
Because a lot of people who are,
let's say, are trying to lose weight,
which I guess is very common use case
for people who want to use Lumen.
If they don't see their weight drop,
within a a day or two,
it's because it's very hard to continue
this ritual.
But if you can guide them on a daily basis,
of okay, you've now transitioned a little bit
more towards the fat burning zone
That makes sense to something that
could be very beneficial.
Yeah, that's true.
And I can say that in the past six years,
we struggled a lot about weight loss
in general. Right?
Because what happens when weight loss
when you succeed? Let's say it works.
And you lose a couple of pounds,
and so why will you use Lumen in a sense?
And what's the value of that ritual?
So, what we focus on is really
about metabolic flexibility.
and metabolic health.
And this is a constant evolution of your body.
Our metabolism changes on a daily basis.
But also really like being in shape
and out of shape, right?
If you run every day, you're in shape.
If you stop running for a week,
you're a bit out of shape.
You're not completely out of shape,
but you're trailing into this.
The same happens with our
metabolic flexibility or metabolic health.
Our ability to use carbs or fats as a fuel,
is they're available or not available.
Fats from our own stores.
And that is something that never dies.
In a way, that's something that you can
constantly improve.
And the nutrition journey people
take upon themselves is one that is
dynamically changing. They start to workout.
Their metabolism changes.
They fly. Now, no one flies.
But they fly and they get jetlagged, right?
So, they go on a vacation.
So, in a sense that's how we see the future.
Even if people come to lose weight.
What we've get them hoped on
eventually is metabolic health.
Which is something sustainable.
I love it. Okay.
So, the second it comes on Amazon
or whatever you're selling it,
please let me know so I can be one
of the first people to purchase it. I will.
It sounds incredible.
And as a person who,
I'm very dedicated to my health.
I'm working out and doing a lot of these
a lot of these research on my own.
It's definitely something that we need.
And it's something that I would find
so useful because that unknown
and that feeling of control that you don’t
really feel like you have over your body
throughout your life.
I think that’s something that’s
really really wonderful.
Daniel, before we go. And I can’t believe
20 minutes are almost over
because I have so many questions.
I want to ask you
the most important question.
Three words that you would best
describe yourself. Or that one of your
co-founders would describe you at.
So, I'll be honest.
I thought about it.
Because that's a tough question.
I think it's a good one though.
It's the hardest question.
So, I think Optimistic would be one.
I'm definitely optimistic in everything I do.
15 years as an entrepreneur Daniel.
Come on. You have to be optimistic.
Yeah. You have to be optimistic.
And in doing some stuff that are
really off the trend.
You know, wellness is a trend.
But hardware, no one will invest in hardware.
Especially the early stages.
It's really hard to build a company that is
doing consumer behavioral changes.
Between hardware and so forth.
So, optimistic is one.
I'm a Learner. I love it.
I look at every experience I'm going through
as a learning phase.
If it's the dynamic with the team,
or if it's understanding CO2
and CO2 sensors and so forth.
And the last one is a leader,
but it's an Aspiration.
So, I aspire to be a good leader.
But not good leader for the community.
Good leader for my team in a sense.
So, this is my focus. And I hope I'm on a
trajectory to do a good job there.
Daniel, toda raba. Thank you so much.
And more success to everything.
It sounds amazing.
Thank you. Sure is.